I've had the flu for the past week but I
got this hat so all is well you know
what we could all really do without I'm
pregnant
No
what's that over there yeah definitely
that but we could also do without you
know those friends that make you feel
weird when you tell them good news like
for example you'd say something like I
do two years of hard work and dedication
I could do the split and then they'd say
fuck you but they say it with a smile
like fuck you but behind that smile
there'd be something in their eyes that
says fuck yeah and you know who I'm
talking about
those bitches with the backhanded
compliments that you can't even begin to
fucking understand you actually tried to
look cute today sweetheart nerd don't
get me started on the ones who just take
take take a hi friend give me your
undivided attention while I proceed to
take up this entire conversation
discussing the romantic dates I've been
on even though they know you've recently
been through a breakup again really is
the time to vent to me right now I am
NOT a listener I at least have some
respect for the ones who don't even try
to hide that they hate your guts
congratulations on that promotion you
deserved it and I fucked your boyfriend
I had a couple of people like this in my
life and you know what no no so last
year I cut out people out of my life who
are like that and it's sad because you
know obviously I don't have a lot of
friends and I know that sounds oddly
pathetic but you know what I am all out
of fucks to give okay the flu took all
my books I like it stay awesome Gotham I
know you want a friend but that's why we
got the internet because the Internet is
our friend you don't have to eat make up
cuz you already pretty on the inside I
feel like this flu is making me
african-american
[Music]